hello everybody welcome back to css3 in
30 days today is day 18 and we're gonna
be coding up some css3 tool tips let me
show you what that looks like right here
in the browser we have the final result
down here and the tool tip is
essentially a little element that just
appears in some position around the
element to let you know a little bit
more information the purpose of a tool
tip is not to look fancy but
specifically to help the user understand
something about what they are
interacting with so from a usability
standpoint let's say this little pink
box I have here is an acronym and you
want to be able to let them know what
that acronym stands for when you hover
over it maybe the tooltip lets them know
what it stands for or maybe there is an
element call to action where if you
hover over it it lets them know
additional information to help them
understand how to interact with that
element a little bit better there's an
endless amount of reasons why you might
want a tooltip but the purpose of this
lesson is not necessarily to show you
the why of the tooltip rather the how to
make a tooltip so let's jump in and
start making tooltips
so in this final result I'm just going
to show you what we're gonna make we got
this top tooltip this right tooltip
bottom tooltip and left tooltip all
we're gonna do is we're going to code up
these these little elements it's just
something to hover over and then we're
gonna make a global tooltip style and
then we're gonna start positioning them
depending on where you hover all in CSS
that's the exciting part about this a
lot of the times tooltips are made using
JavaScript or jQuery
but in this case just css3 because
that's how we roll in css3 and 30 days
over here in the code editor we have our
18 tooltips take a moment to go and
download that and open up your index and
sandbox final that CSS is always there
for your reference as you go along if
you mess something up or if you confused
about something that should help you out
otherwise let's get started here in the
index I'm gonna show you what the
mark-up looks like because it is a
little bit important because we're gonna
be styling it so into sandbox here we
have just some divs and the div they all
have the class of tooltip and then the
position of where it will be so the
class
simply top right bottom and left they
all have the class of tooltip the other
thing is there is a title attribute with
some text I've just said to tooltip on
top right and so on and so forth and
that is really it for the markup in the
sandbox we're gonna get started and
we're gonna style our tooltip element
itself so that the the target that we
want to hover over so we're going to
select tooltip and then we're just going
to say position relative this is
important because we're going to be
positioning that tooltip itself so right
now we're positioning the parent element
that we call tooltip but it has to have
a position of relative or absolute
whichever one you choose in this case
we're going to use relative so it
doesn't move around in weird places and
that's simply so that when we position
the tooltip itself using the before and
after virtual elements we need to have
it stay contained within its parent so
position relativism very important in
this case height 60 pixels again this is
just the target we're gonna hover over a
dime just jam in here 250 pixels
background we're gonna use that the pink
color that branded pink that's F two
three nine five a whatever color you
want really doesn't matter this isn't a
functionality this is just some this is
just vanity styles here
text-align:center we're gonna line
height the text in the center of it to
sixty pixels which is gonna be the same
as the height so it's vertically aligned
as well as Center aligned because of
text-align:center
fondle 18 pixels margin:0 auto and
that's how you style a target element
boom just like that nice okay let's go
back to the the sandbox here and let's
get coding up the tooltip itself so
we're going to just say tooltip but
we're gonna actually select the before
pseudo element this whole time have been
calling them virtual elements I think I
made that up
maybe I didn't but the idea is that it
is a pseudo element it's not a real
element it's kind of an element that
doesn't really appear unless you make it
do something so it's just a funky little
CSS trick
again I've been calling them virtual
elements this this whole time and I
think I made that up but we still got
the job done right Brad right Brad
position we're gonna position:absolute
because we want to move that around
freely outside of the flow we don't
really want position relative to be
messing with it so position absolutes
gonna give us some more flexibility is
that index too just a little bit above
the default which too tooltip will be at
zero and then this one will bring it up
just a little bit we don't want it to be
behind its parent element display:none
by default with 200 pixels padding 10
pixels so something nice and simple font
size I'm gonna go 0.8 that's 80% of the
parent elements font size which is 18
pixels so 80% of the 80% of that
whatever whatever that number is line
height one point for em let's try that
and border-radius we're gonna say five
pixels slightly rounded background color
we're gonna go with an RGB a something
that you can see through simply a zero
zero zero and zero point eight so it's
black but 80% alpha Channel so a little
bit transparent color white that's the
text the content this is cool content
used with the before and after pseudo
elements to generate content specific
text within an element so we've been
using this a lot in this way but they
were actually gonna this means you can
actually put text within the element
we're just putting an empty string
because it allows that after element to
appear so we still need to have content
within the pseudo element but we're
actually going to have it display real
content this time not just an empty
string so we're just going to do
something fun here so instead of an
empty string we're actually gonna use
attribute value this says attribute
value for the content property so this
is specific a specific value for this
property which means we have access to
within this parentheses a specific
attribute within the HTML so we want to
grab the title that title we
specifically put in the HTML will say
tooltip on the right tool tip on the
bottom so on and so forth so that is
cool dynamic it's
not just hard coded so this will depend
on whatever the title is of that element
really exciting stuff I'm so pumped okay
we're gonna now select tool tip after
pseudo-element and now before we get
move forward let's actually just see if
this that did anything so I'm going to
move over to the browser and it doesn't
do anything because we haven't done any
styles upon hover so we're gonna work on
that let me actually let's just do that
now so we can so we can make it appear
so tooltip hover and then the before so
how that works is the tooltip the
tooltip element when we hover over the
tooltip element do something with the
before pseudo element so it's a kind of
an interesting little selector so
display:inline-block watch this save
that now when I hover nothing happens
exactly what I wanted now you might be
wondering why that little thing pops up
when you say there that's just the title
attribute appearing by default the
browsers need of functionality it shows
the title just for accessibility but we
actually want to make our own so back to
the original problem we don't see it I'm
thinking that's because okay super silly
just realized this I was styling here's
the problem maybe you notice this and
you were just shaking your head
wondering when I was going to catch it i
styled tooltip after pseudo element I
meant to style these tooltip before
pseudo element and then down here I said
on hover show the before element which
we haven't done anything with so let's
change that to before and top we're
gonna take that out because I'm actually
going to use that save that and then on
hover that should work let's see what
happens here there it is okay so the
tooltip on top appears there it's at the
very it's somewhere at the top right I
don't really know what's going on with
its position so we need to fix that plus
we need to do one little thing I want to
show a little arrow pointing towards the
element itself so down here in the final
example I want it to look like that has
a little arrow so I'm gonna create that
little arrow with
the after pseudo-element which I was
accidentally styling this whole time so
that's gonna be like this
position:absolute zet index we're gonna
say 1 it's gonna be above the parent but
behind the little tooltip itself and
then I'm gonna say display:none again by
default we don't wanna see it
width:0 height:0 and this is because
we're gonna make it we're going to make
a triangle out of a border like we did
with pac-man just recently here so we're
gonna say border 5 pixels solid
transparent so we don't see any of the
border and then a little bit later here
I'm gonna create and display one side of
it so let's just leave it at that
and then we're gonna say content empty
string so that will create an element
that we still won't see and we're gonna
do something within a sec so let's
position that let's let's say we're
gonna go bottom zero no 100% so the very
bottom of the element left 50% border
top color
tooltip zero zero zero zero point five
zero point eight RGBA
let's say that and see what just
happened okay so I don't see it and that
is because we're actually on hover up
here where are we right here we need to
make the after pseudo element appear on
hover as well tooltip hover after so
save that but I'm going to put this
style after that hover simply because
it's cascading I don't want the this
style to be before this just in case
there's some sort of problem okay so
something is happening here so when I
hover now you can see the arrow it's the
right shape shape and size but it's in
the wrong spot so we need to move that
in the right spot so what do we gotta do
to do that it has to be in the center of
this element
let's start by centering the tooltip
itself because it's obviously in the
wrong spot needs to be centered and then
above the element so let's go ahead and
do that let's go back to the tool tip
top before and what we're gonna do is
we're going to position it now in a so
we're gonna say bottom now if I just
said bottom 100% what's gonna happen
it's gonna move it up but I want to add
another five pixels to that so because
the the the size of that arrow is five
pixels because we said in our border
five pixels so we want it to be 100%
from the bottom but then another five
pixels now we can't find out that it we
can't create that with a percentage but
I also want to have a dynamic tooltip
position from the bottom because that
element could be any size if I want to
add a tool tip to any element not just
the specific hard-coded height so it
needs to be 100% from the bottom but it
needs to have an additional five pixels
and the way we can combine a percentage
and a pixel value is through the calc
CSS function so check this out
let's go back to our CSS I'm gonna wrap
this in the calc function like this but
I'm gonna say plus five pixels that
allows us to combine different values
different measurements and watch this
100% plus five pixels that's amazing how
cool is that so now we need to fix that
it needs to move it over so let me let
me do another thing here we're going to
we gotta move it left let's say left 50%
save that let's see what happens okay so
now we're 50% over now we're starting to
look at 50% over from the left side of
the parent element as you could see as
well as the little arrow is it's in the
bottom left hand corner of the tooltip
but we need to fix that we need to move
it back over so how we do that is
through a we could just simply say
margin-left you know you know- whatever
the width is of the element but I want
to use transform the reason why is
because this is kind of an animated
elements it's kind of appearing you know
through a fade and I just want to want
to use this as an example I could just
use the margin left or positioning but
here's the deal there I found a really
cool article about the transform
specifically what I'm going to do is
this and I'll tell you exactly why so
translate X so translate the value for
the transform property on the x axis
which means horizontally so I'm gonna
say negative 50% no let me show you what
it happens and then we're gonna go from
there so now we're perfectly in the
center so I moved it negative 50% of its
width over so that it is perfectly in
the center the reason why I used
transform translate is because this
article is a great article I have a link
in the final code in the at this line 58
of the final CSS with the link to this
article it's basically I wanted to know
okay why would you want to use translate
versus an absolute position or you know
using a margin where you can you know
negative the amount so it's centered
which we've done before well he
basically says don't confuse positioning
with designing motion so here's an
example when you use an element that has
an absolute position or a margin you
know negative pixel position it's going
the browser is going to render that
animation if you're moving it at all
pixel by pixel so this is cool so in the
animation if you were to view the source
code and you animated it into that
position it's going to go pixel - no -
pixels 3 pixels 4 pixels until it goes
from whatever whatever starting pixel to
the end pixel pixel by pixel so
technically that's pretty choppy
especially if you had a really good
Retina screen where you can see the
little fine details but
that's not the best practice how do you
do it so that's more smooth so it's a
renders a bit more smooth well you use
translate the transform translate where
the browser does something like this it
renders that animation way smoother so
it goes in increments so you can see it
goes from the starting of zero let's say
and the final the final pixel that you
end on is one pixel it doesn't just go
zero to one it goes
zero point one point two point three
point four point five all the way up to
your final position so that it's a
really smooth animation so the way
Arthur I believe is the author here he
says don't confuse positioning so I'm
moving an element in a specific and
static and hard-coded place with design
II motion so possibly I'm thinking here
maybe our pac-man instead of using you
know the moving the pixels across the
screen maybe I would have used transform
translate X to move him across the
screen that might be something that you
might want to revisit to see if we can
improve that instead of using absolute
positioning using transform translate so
my little rant on why you would use
transform translate
I'm simply positioning it in an area but
because it's gonna be fading in and
because you could have it slide up or
slide down into position using the
transform property is a nicer way of
handling its position because it's a bit
more dynamic hopefully that makes sense
and I didn't go off on a tangent for no
reason whatsoever
okay so now we've got our tooltip in the
right position we want that little arrow
to be in the right position so let's
find the tooltip after and just for
consistency I'm going to move this hover
above these styles
like so and then down here we're gonna
start styling the after so what happens
let me see I'm gonna move down a couple
and we said bottom 100 percent and left
50 percent so that's good but what we
actually need to do now is if you can
see it needs to be centered properly
it's not actually in the center of the
tool tip so let's try that transform
translate X again and then say negative
50% and I'll see what it does to it so
now it is actually perfectly centered
this is the same width on the left as it
is on the right perfect but it's not
below the tool tip we want to be able to
see that that's because let's see if I
can do this this is the top border of an
element of a 5 pixel border and so there
are three other sides that you can't see
so we just need to make the border
bottom with 0 so that should jump that
whole element down so let's try that so
we're gonna say border bottom width 0
now I could have just used position
bottom 100% calc and then extra 5 pixels
but I just want to make it easy instead
of doing anything else and just say
border bottom with 0 so now the border
top width is 5 pixels the border bottom
width is nothing so that should collapse
it down below the tooltip let's see
just like I said it would do so that now
means that the border bottom of that
element is zero you can't it's nothing
they're taking up space and it jumps
that arrow down so that it's just
touching the tooltip on the top so there
is our top tooltip that's it for that
that style right there so now all of
them have these styles so that's a
little bit of a problem because they
need to be a bit more specific so the
styles are just dialed were for all the
tooltips so maybe we'll go back into our
CSS here
and what we're going to do is revisit
here so the tooltip hover it's going to
display all the tooltips on hover we
want that but now what we want for for
the tooltip top so we want all the
tooltips to have these styles but this
style is specific to the tooltip top so
I'm gonna cut that out and what I'm
gonna do is this so I'm gonna actually
go down to the bottom and I'm gonna say
tooltip and then I'm gonna combine that
with the class of top and then the after
pseudo-element I believe it was before
actually was the style we were going for
yes so that is the tooltip itself the
position of the top tooltip save that
okay perfect so now these ones are
broken because I'm not selecting them
anymore that is more of what we wanted
but we also did the after the position
of that arrow is wrong so we need to
specifically take yes so we're going to
take all these styles because that's
specific to where it's going to be
positioned so now this is just styling
all that all of those elements as in
terms of its look and feel but the
position of it we want to be very
specific so now down here I'm gonna say
tooltip top and then the after
pseudo-element I add these styles so now
let's try that tooltip top works great
these ones broken beautiful okay so a
quick review we have the tooltip global
style just for that pink element we have
the when you hover the before-and-after
elements will appear well we'll get a
display of inline block the default
tooltip the four Styles in fact why
don't we just move these up
reorganizing my code a little bit here
so tool tip and then tool pit tool tip
after and tilt it before okay so we got
those three things and then we have tool
tip hover before and after then we have
tool tip top before
that's position to get that in the top
center position above the the pink
element and then tool to top after which
is a little arrow in the bottom in the
center that is good
so moving on that was the was the bulk
of the work I think because now what
we're going to be doing is just
positioning the we already styled up the
tool tip now we're just need to position
them so that looks so that the tool tip
is on the other right bottom or left and
the arrows are in the their respective
positions so rolling up our sleeves here
we're gonna get started let's go down
here below tool tip top after give a
little bit of space and now what we're
going to do is we're gonna be styling
the tool tip let's do the one on the the
right that's the next one tool tip right
so those are connected that's a very
specific selector I'm selecting the
class of tool tip that also has the
class of right and before pseudo-element
now we're going to do is we're going to
say top 50% because it needs to be in
the center of the elements so if we look
over here we need that to be centered in
vertically so let's go back here and
we're going to say left here's what
we're going to do so we're going to say
left
we're gonna go calc again the calc
function 100% from the left now let's
see what's going on here if I save that
check it out it's going to be all the
way over there
the problem here is a couple things it's
we need to have some space for the arrow
on that in between the two elements so
we're going to do the calc one hundred
percent plus five pixels that will give
us that space perfect and the other
problem is the the vertical on the
y-axis that tooltip on the right is just
centered from the top we need to be
centered from the the middle of the
element that makes sense so we're also
going to go transform translate y so
that's on the y axis negative 50% save
that check it out so now we're in the
right spot now we need to get that arrow
and we need to make that appear properly
so now we're going to style tool tip
with the class of right and the after
pseudo-element
we're going to say border right color
whoops is rgba I want to type all this
out so I'm going to copy that
the RGB be a zero zero zero zero point
eight and then the border we're gonna
say top 50% so we wanted to be down 50%
and then left 100% so let's let's see
what that does
okay so from the left it's 100% because
the parent element is here so left 100%
I believe that's the case
yep well let's see if it is left zero
we'll see what happens yes so see how
it's over here now what the other thing
is do you see how there's a little bit
of space how it's not actually connected
to the left side of the element that's
because the other three sides of the
border 1 2 & 3 are invisible they're
transparent but that the width is still
there so I want the left width of the
border to be 0 so let's do that right
now we're gonna say border left wit 0
now check it out now we're right at this
the left side now we need to position
that to be left 100% like we were
originally doing but the problem here is
it's not actually aligned in the center
of that tooltip and we're going to fix
that with the transform property
transform immigrants a translate y and
you guessed it negative 50% and that is
going to do the trick I believe there it
is so the tooltip on the right is done
so now
should be able to zip through that was
only about three minutes to coat that up
now our bottom and left should be super
easy so let's jump down to our bottom so
now a little bit of space I'm just gonna
space these out a little bit so it's
easier to find them good organization so
now we're going to solve that bottom so
we're gonna go tool tip that also has
the class of bottom and the before
pseudo-element the top we're going to
need to let's see look at here so we're
in the bottom it needs to be 100% down
from the top so top will be calc we're
going to do calc again 100% plus the
five pixels for that little arrow now
we're going to do is going to go left
50% because we want to be little to be
centered but that's going to create a
problem again check it out it's going to
be left from the left side we need to
take off half of though of the width so
it's Center so we're gonna use that
transform and we're gonna use translate
on the x-axis translate X and then
that's gonna be negative 50% save that
that should get us in the center looking
very nice now we just need to position
that after pseudo-element
tooltip bottom after okay
top 100 percent left 50% we're going to
go border bottom color because we want
it to appear now rgba 0 0 0 0.8 save
that let's see what we got
so I can see it there it's right there
but it's not centered in the middle of
the tooltip and it needs to be up 5
pixels so maybe you guessed it border
top width 0 and transform translate X
negative 50% save that refresh tooltip
on the bottom that's looking nice and
last but not least tooltip on the left
so we're gonna give a little bit of
space in between here we're going to say
tooltip also with the class of left and
the before pseudo-element
this is kind of like repetition now at
this point you might even be able to do
this by yourself I challenge you in fact
the video would keep me in this frame
right here
that one and code this one up yourself
and then hit play see if you got it
right so here we are you've paused the
video and you've coded it up and you're
gonna see if you got this right now keep
in mind there's multiple ways of doing
getting to the same end result but
here's how I'm gonna code it up and
let's see how close you were I'm gonna
say top 50% right and needs to be 100%
but I need to calculate that with a
pixel wit so 100% from the right plus 5
pixels to account for that little arrow
transform we're gonna trance trance late
that on the y-axis and we're gonna go
negative 50% let's check it out that's
looking nice and now here we go we're
just gonna simply say tool tip with the
class of left and after we're gonna say
top 50% left
nope that's not right right 100% we're
gonna go border left color because we
want the left arrow to appear and we're
gonna say border right with zero so
where there's no conflict with the size
there transform translates on the y-axis
it's gonna be negative 50% save that
boom I think we just nailed it so if
that's what your code looks like or
something like that good job you've got
the hang of it
that's it for tool tips we've got tool
tip on the top right bottom and left
purely css3 that's awesome it's really
lightweight when you do that in css3 we
did a couple new things we played around
with the transform property which we
learned a little bit about why you might
want to do that particularly with
animations a little challenge for you
here if you want because right now these
tooltips are just up hearing on hover
now we've played around with some
animations thus far in this css3 in 30
days and we you should know or maybe you
should be able to figure out how to when
you hover make the tooltips fade in or
maybe you know slide in slide down or
slide over play around with it and see
what you come up with I challenge you to
make these tooltips a little bit more
and keep in mind the transform and
translate style that we learned about
positioning and moving things using that
where it incrementally moves into the
position rather than uses a hard-coded
position app absolutely positioned
property where it's only clunking over
pixel-by-pixel keep that in mind but a
simple challenge for you is to make
these tooltips fade in on hover and play
with it from there
I hope you enjoyed today's lesson hope
it gave you a few ideas for your own
websites applications and all of that
have a good day I'll see you tomorrow
and date number 19 the Essene UAV
adios
[Music]